l'image que donne en particulier et les
filles et absolument effrayante pourquoi
je veux dire transformer l'Assemblée
nationale en camp de gitan et c'est pas
les Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer je veux
dire il faut arrêter de donner ce
spectacle et de dégrader cette
république au point que maintenant tous
les jours sur les radios à la télé on
vous dit regardez il y a du monde dans
la rue donc il faut tout arrêter c'est
pas ça la démocratie
artiste gitan et mon ami ça va mon frère
comment ça va Jean très bien j'ai un peu
d'oseille
tu parles de quoi on m'a mis trois et
demi
alors et donc on a revu l'extrait pour
toi tu as été blessé tu peux être que
blessé tu as entendu les promos les
propos c'est une expression tout ça
moi c'est possible pas lui tu comprends
son métier c'est de parler mon frère il
fait ça ils sont payés une tonne à
parler et c'est pas des gens du peuple
son compte c'est ce qui vient de dire
c'est stigmatisant à mort pour toute une
communauté
il nous parle de nous comme si on était
sous-catégorie est-ce que tu as vu c'est
à dire juste avant il dit c'est
effrayant tu imagines alors il parlait
de l'Assemblée
à remplacer
gitan par un autre motel franchement
mais ça serait dommage ou pas mais tu
imagines ce qu'il a dit mais je crois
que les gens mais lui je pense qu'il a
pas voulu alors je sens vouloir le
défendre je pense que lui il s'est dit
voilà c'est une expression commune mais
il a pas vu en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que les expressions comme ça c'est
devenu du racisme ordinaire et que les
gens les reprennent comme ça sans se
rendre compte que c'est une expression
qui peut mine de rien blesser énormément
de gens ben alors ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que tu alors tu as la télé
quand même ton métier c'est de parler tu
peux dire alors les Juifs font de
l'argent les matchs
enfin les musulmans c'est des
terroristes c'est pas possible malade
ces gens c'est des grands malades et il
faut il faut vous dire que nous on est
victime du racisme à mort je sais ça
veut dire que je peux pas je pense que
on est une des communautés les plus
victimes du racisme en France
et aujourd'hui quand elle était je suis
devant ma télé je suis devant mes trucs
et je vois ce truc là mais ça me donne
envie de vomir tu comprends mon vin
parce qu'il faut il faut savoir que ça
touche des travailleurs bien sûr qui
travaille il faut savoir que nous dès
qu'on est gitans des formats pour
travailler ici ils apprennent qu'on est
gitans ils arrêtent je sais c'est un
truc tu comprends c'est un truc de fou
et tu peux pas laisser des mecs comme ça
arrivait dire ce qu'ils veulent tu
imagines est-ce que tu as vu les propos
vous en avez entendu c'est honteux et
moi je veux dire et je dis moi j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup de potes gitan il y a
vraiment j'en ai plein et c'est vraiment
des mecs d'une droiture d'une d'une
fidélité incroyable vraiment c'est plus
le racisme c'est que la mode depuis
c'est pas c'est que c'est une expression
qui est rentrée et les mecs la sorte
comme ça comme si de rien n'était en
fait c'est ça Valérie c'est ça le pro
c'est le problème c'est qu'effectivement
c'est comme vous disiez c'est du racisme
ordinaire parce que il y a énormément
d'expression dans la langue française
comme ça qu'il faudrait éradiquer et
éradiquer parce que elles sont quasiment
vidées de leur sens on oublie ce qu'elle
ce qu'elle dise en fait et elles disent
des choses d'une grande violence et donc
il faudrait et en plus effectivement les
politiques leur métier c'est de parler
donc il faut qu'il fasse attention à
leurs propos ce que leur propos ne sont
pas anodins ils sont pas au bistrot on
n'est pas on n'est pas au comptoir entre
discuter entre amis
vous n'êtes pas choqué non moi je suis
pas choqué parce que j'ai pas vu ça
comme une insulte
pas ça
j'ai des copains gitans j'en ai pas
parlé parce que voilà je découvre
tout le temps politique d'avoir un
langage technocratique on comprend rien
ce qu'il raconte
gitan ça veut dire que c'est un peu pour
moi c'est genre c'est le brouhaha ça
parle fort dans tous les sens c'est
comme gitan
quand j'y pense c'est pas le salon du
rangement
c'est ce qu'il vient de dire
parce que je pense pas que tu le
veuilles tu te rends pas compte de ce
que tu dis les gens ça veut dire que les
gens s'imaginent après c'est-à-dire dès
qu'ils vont être chez moi oui mais toi
j'ai pas dit sans le vouloir tu viens de
faire l'Allemagne La Malga aussi ça veut
dire que tu vois le truc déranger oh
mais ça s'agitant au de ça on dirait un
petit manouche et j'aime pas ça non tu
as pas dit ça je te dis merci non mais
j'ai pas dit je crois que j'ai été clair
dans mes propos quand j'ai parlé avec
lui je t'ai dit mais sans le vouloir tu
te rends pas compte je vais te donner un
exemple ma petite elle va à l'école ma
petite elle va à l'école c'est le
carnaval tu sais ce qu'on lui dit ma
petite elle avait toujours peur de pas
avoir de déguisement je te jure je te
mens pas c'est une vérité
donc elle dit à la maîtresse je peux
avoir comment je fais un déguisement tu
vois la femme elle lui dit écoute je
regarde ce qu'elle lui dit elle lui dit
découpe des rideaux des vieux rideaux on
va dans une friperie tu te déguises en
gitane elle dit ça ma fille ma fille
elle rentre de l'école toute contente
mon père n'achète pas de costume elle me
dit j'essaie la maîtresse elle m'a donné
une bonne idée
elle me dit ça j'ai envie de vomir j'ai
appelé la maîtresse je me suis mis hors
de moi tu te rends compte mon frère oh
non 2023 s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
un peu de respect pour ma communauté un
peu de respect pour toutes les
communautés oh on est dans le vivre
ensemble ou pas c'est quoi ces gens
diviseur là c'est des diviseurs ça tu
vois pas ils veulent pas que on s'aime
ils veulent diviser pour mieux régner et
moi je suis désolé pour moi c'est pas
une insulte
les mots sont faits pour être écoutés
bon moi de toute façon je suis par
principe contre toute forme de
stigmatisation de de racisme
d'essentialisation des gens maintenant
est-ce que ce sénateur a commis un
propos raciste pour lequel il devrait
être sanctionné je ne le crois pas s'il
avait dit quand on rentre à l'Assemblée
nationale on est dans le souk est-ce
qu'on aurait dit c'est un propos
stigmatisant à l'égard des communautés
maghrébines je pense pas
lorsque cette année
pas du tout
une chose est de s'attaquer à un
individu d'accord de l'animaliser la
sédure racisme d'accord
mais moi ce que je supporte pas si vous
voulez cette espèce de terrorisme
intellectuel au nom duquel on a plus
besoin
de rien dire
on a une on a normalement et les hommes
publics les communicants encore plus une
liberté d'expression évidemment la
liberté d'expression n'autorise pas tout
je suis d'accord donc si il y a
effectivement des gens qui se sentent
blessés ce que je comprends tout à fait
le propos à mon avis était malade à
droite j'aurais pas utilisé ce propos là
il était maladroit au pire ou troncier
est-ce qu'il est raciste je crois pas je
crois pas que ça soit de la ciganophonie
c'est ce que tu as dit je pense que
c'est dur à diversité
je vais dire cette explosion c'est du
racisme des complexée mais je pense pas
qu'il est voulu tu vois il aurait pu
mais je comprends moi que tu sois vexé
en fait le ce cette mousse a été montée
par elephi par la France insoumise
excusez-moi c'est l'hôpital qui se fout
de la charité les gens de la et les
filles qui ont traité Elisabeth borne de
rescapé au moment où elle fait son
discours de politique générale où
rappelle qu'elle est rescapée de la
choco ce que sa famille est rescapé de
la Shoah Mathilde de panneau le dit que
vous êtes une rescapé ensuite vous avez
Daniel obono et Daniel Simonet qui
invitent un antisémite notoire Jérémy
Corbel Jérémy corbine bien sûr la France
alors c'est pas moi je ne qui était
choqué ça tous les bords politiques sauf
la France
et maintenant la France insoumise vient
donner des leçons de vous trompez pas de
protecteur et ne vous trompez pas
d'adversaire
de la France insoumise je pense vraiment
que je le connais un peu et donc ils
sont et en fait c'est la France
insoumise qui a voulu politiser le truc
et là je suis d'accord avec son Messia
et lui il sent car le cul vraiment des
connexions avec ce qu'on veut il pense à
lui et à ce qui vit toute la journée
est-ce qu'il vit au quotidien pense pas
à la récupération politique mais c'est
vrai qu'ils ont voulu faire de la
récupération politique mais je pense que
lui il a parlé plus avec son cœur que il
a pensé à Mathieu panneau ou à
Clémentine au thym ou tu as raison elle
a LFI qui qui qui qui qui
donner des leçons après ça je suis
d'accord avec toi oui je suis d'accord
pour une fois que j'en mets ça sur le la
récupération politique hors de propos
tentation mais revenons à kanjitan qui
s'accompagne d'eux ce n'est pas les
Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer donc là le côté
l'expression comme ça un peu
passe-partout non parce que c'est pas
les Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer il a plu
exactement et donc Jean excusez-moi mais
nous sommes là littéralement dans une
injure raciste c'est-à-dire qui
stigmatise qui est méprisante envers
toute une communauté
est-ce que le racisme se décrète
simplement parce que je suis choqué
est-ce que c'est le ressenti qui fait
que c'est raciste ou pas la définition
du racisme c'est outrageant
j'ai cru comprendre pour toi moi je
n'aurais pas utilisé
est-ce qu'ils sont méprisants méprisants
je sais pas ils sont tranquilles ils
sont maladroits
dit qu'ils ont bordélisé le pays est-ce
qu'on l'a accusé de stigmatiser les
travailleurs du sexe
un mauvais exemple juste ici il s'est
excusé Hervé Marseille
l'instrumentalisation de mes propos par
les filles et nausées je suis assez
d'accord j'ai sûrement fait preuve
d'imprudence verbale et je n'ai voulu
évidemment blesser personne je regrette
cette situation mais regardez ce qu'ils
font de l'Assemblée nationale là on peut
être que d'accord avec lui est-ce que
vous acceptez ces excuses dans la mesure
où tu c'est plus sincèrement voilà bien
sûr qu'on accepte les excuses mais moi
je peux pas parler
toi déjà moi j'accepte voilà maintenant
ma communauté je sais pas tu sais on en
a marre on voudrait être représenté mon
frère on voudrait être représenté par
quelqu'un qui
qui connaît notre vie c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui ça ça peut pas pourquoi
tu viens pas
autour de la table
c'est ça ton problème
toi toujours c'est ça ton problème viens
on parle ensemble après toujours regarde
ça c'est représenté c'est pas représente
tatie de la France pourquoi pas
un être humain pourquoi vous dites sans
déconnexion
et vous vivez pas ce qu'on vit nous
c'est à dire que les mecs tu sais toi au
quotidien c'est dur pour toi mais bien
sûr mon ami tu es obligé alors pour pas
que il faut se cacher mentir pas dire ce
que tu es attends il y a pas il y a
quelqu'un qui il y a quelqu'un qui m'a
dit aussi même même au niveau des
banques des ouvertures de compte et bien
sûr sachez-le pour les gitans c'est très
dur mais je vous le dis c'est très dur
parce que les banques les refusent
souvent alors on dit que c'est trop dur
mais tu vois il y a la DEAL Adil Rami
c'est un truc qui fait des prêts ils
m'ont contacté il y a pas longtemps ils
nous ont dit les gitans on veut
travailler qu'avec vous vous êtes les
meilleurs meilleurs qu'il existe et ils
nous aide pour ouvrir des entreprises
qu'on rembourse c'est des crédits en
bourse c'est-à-dire
c'est un bon procédé il est venu me voir
c'est mal Coluche chez les gens du
voyage nous on voudrait que des
voyageurs parce que vous êtes les
meilleurs rembourseurs je vous jure que
c'est vrai c'est un truc de fou et
aujourd'hui je comprends pas que qu'on
est aussi mal vu mais qu'est-ce qu'on a
pu faire à ce pays qu'est-ce qu'on a pu
faire de grave pour qu'on soit aussi
détesté mon ami j'aurais qu'on écoute
juste vous oui non mais oui l'expression
est maladroite mais moi j'en ai marre de
cette espèce de démagogie à géométrie
variable il y a des gens qui tout d'un
coup sont choqués qui font comme si
c'était une cause qui les intéressait
alors qu'en fait pas du tout et qui font
juste ça pour se faire bien voir donc
voilà c'est c'est au bout d'un moment et
il y a surtout un vrai décalage entre la
manière dont on parle dans la vraie vie
et la manière dont on parle sur les
plateaux télé et effectivement il y a
des expressions qu'on utilise tous dans
la vraie vie qui peuvent être perçues
comme stigmatisante et quand on est dit
à la télé ça passe pas parce qu'il y a
un tel ou tel qui va se sentir choqué
donc l'expression elle est maladroite
est-ce que ça veut dire que ce monsieur
a une haine envers la communauté des
gitans je ne pense pas il s'est excusé
il a eu bien eu raison mais alors
je n'espère pas alors ça je suis
d'accord avec toi je suis d'accord avec
toi nous on peut faire l'erreur par
exemple sur ce plateau aujourd'hui mais
pas quand tu es sûr monsieur ça c'est la
terre attention je pense qu'il a pas il
a il a pas pu le truc partir c'est bon
il s'est excusé tout ce que tu veux on
est bien d'accord mais c'est à dire qu'à
un moment quand tu es tu sais quand tu
as changé tu te trompes tu fais une
erreur une erreur de de frappe tu
blesses
toi tu as fait deux trois erreurs j'ai
vu 3 semaines
c'est ton travail il a fait une erreur
je pense qu'il mérite pour moi d'être
sanctionné pour pas que d'autres qui se
mettent ça dans la tête et qui disent je
ne recommence pas après il y a pas mort
d'homme après après
ce qui voilà il s'est pris beaucoup avec
qui je pense qu'il est là il a compris
je pense que les autres ne le refont pas
euh genre on voulait dire un truc après
je connais Delphine oui parce qu'en fait
ce qui ce qui peut paraître choquant
également c'est que ce monsieur sénateur
est un sénateur centriste donc
évidemment autoproclamer humaniste etc
et le fait qu'il se sente avec son
idéologie d'ouverture de tolérance etc
qui se sont autorisés à prononcer des
paroles qui sont effectivement à
l'encontre de son logiciel hydraulique
là effectivement ça peut ça peut poser
question et j'ajoute que je veux dire le
camp de gitan excusez-moi quand on voit
l'historique de l'ancien patron de l'UDI
Jean-Christophe Lagarde qui a des
enfants
innommable on avait un carnet qui va lui
faire signer tous les trois mois ça veut
dire que on a été interdit aussi d'avoir
un logement interdit d'accéder à la
propriété interdit c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque on était déjà malheureux donc
le malheur la saleté mais je vais vous
dire les j'ai acheté des maisons vous
savez en Auvergne
Express
il y avait beaucoup de maisons il y
avait pas de toilette c'est pas pour ça
qu'on dit les Français ou les gens de la
fin tu vois que les gens sont sales ça
veut dire aussi et l'expression aussi tu
manges en Juifs
tu manges tout seul moi chaque fois que
je mange tout seul on me dit tu manges
au jus avec moi
je comprends ce que tu veux dire ça
devient de là c'est à dire c'est des
expressions il y a 100 ans que les gens
se transmettent de génération en
génération mais viens dans un terrain de
gitan il y a pas plus propre que nous il
n'y a pas plus propre le goudron parce
qu'on est sur du goudron on lave le
goudron mon ami venez manger chez nous
on est même
donc ça veut dire que aujourd'hui il n'y
a plus de débordement entre la
communauté gitane et les communes
de plus de 5000 habitants se doit
d'avoir une place désigne ça dirait un
lieu d'accueil pour les gens du voyage
dans chaque commune il faut qu'il
y a c'est la loi c'est pas nous qui
l'avons créé c'est la loi d'accord
on paye l'emplacement on paye
l'électricité on paye l'eau à des tarifs
allez vous renseigner sur le tarif sans
APL ça veut dire que déjà on coupe pas
bien cher enfin bref tout ça pour vous
dire que venez chez nous venez voir chez
nous la propre camp des gens venez voir
venez sur les places désignées venez
voir l'accueil que vous aurez venez voir
les gens propres venez voir les gens qui
travaillent
exactement venez à 7h du matin vous
allez voir les camions en route tous les
matins les camions en route qui
préchauffent vous allez voir tout tout
il faut préchauffer on sait jamais les
diesel tu sais c'est plus que c'était
en même temps et puis pardon mais c'est
pas parce qu'il y a des débordements
qu'on doit essentialiser une communauté
c'est pas parce qu'il y a parfois des
brebis galeuses comme à chaque fois ici
on dit par exemple pour la police
parfois il y a des débordements avec la
police
réaliser non mais c'est bon quoi
moi je considère que c'est insultant et
dégradant et c'est vraiment une
expression une expression existe et je
demande pourquoi quand il y a des avis
d'expulsion de la part de communes et
ben vous ne partez pas pourquoi est-ce
que quand il y a la police qui vient
vous ne partez pas et c'est là que ça
fait des débordements pour toi
la commune respecte pas la loi
c'est-à-dire que la commune elle a la
loi la mer le maire doit respecter la
loi mais s'il a respecté il est là pour
montrer l'exemple moi pauvre citoyens si
tu la respectes pas pourquoi tu vas
m'obliger à respecter c'est ce que je te
dis c'est parce que je fais moi ce que
je veux dire ce n'est pas normal alors
il y a des gens qui demandent est-ce que
vous vous n'utilisez pas des expressions
voilà parfois voilà bien sûr ça arrive
ça m'arrive complètement mais pas la
télé d'accord tu comprends la différence
ah la télé je passe sénateur ça m'arrive
de faire des erreurs mais pas la télé
c'est à dire que moi ce que je veux plus
je vais te dire la vérité ce que je veux
plus que ça arrive c'est que ces gens-là
ils banalisent une banalise qu'on vit
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui il faut
savoir qu'on vit vraiment une époque
pour nous et c'est de plus en plus dur
avec le reportage enquêté exclusif qui
banalise cette haine après le voyage je
veux plus qu'on puisse pouvoir dire ce
qu'on veut sur nous je veux qu'il y a
des associations des gens qui nous
représentent et qui décident qui
décident comme comme d'autres
communautés qui décident de mon frère
toi tu es toujours séparer les musulmans
il est sérieux je veux dire en fait en
France il n'y a pas de haine de principe
envers une communauté envers une autre
les Francs je pense pas que les Français
essentialise une haine unidirectionnée
des généralisée sur une communauté par
contre il y a effectivement parfois des
comportements de rejet lorsque certaines
à un certain nombre de certaines
communautés et bien euh entrave la loi
alors
voilà donc en France on rejette pas
quelqu'un pour ce qu'il est pour ce qui
fait c'est pas pareil
quand je vois quelqu'un qui est pas de
ma communauté que je passe à la rue avec
mon enfant c'est pas pour ça que je le
traîne vers moi j'ai dans l'espérance
que comme que ça n'est pas tu comprends
ce que je veux te dire maintenant
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il y a des gens
chez les chez les gens du voyage il y a
des gens qui voleur non mais il y a des
gitans voleurs
moi je veux juste dire que là tout le
monde parle à tort et à travers le sujet
là qui nous intéresse c'est un mec qui
représente la République un député c'est
la vraisemblème nationale on ne doit pas
se priver d'utiliser même une expression
millénaire si on le veut il n'a pas le
droit de le faire donc
les autres en prennent de la graine
voilà il s'est excusé voilà on va on va
voir juste la vie du radine après
être très intéressant en revanche non
mais si ce n'est pas oui parce que
j'interpellais tout à l'heure des films
mais c'est vrai tu as raison moi j'ai
trouvé ça très investisseur avait dit
par exemple tout à l'heure vous avez
utilisé l'expression manger en juif s'il
avait utilisé cette expression ou si il
avait dit par exemple je vais pas
débattre en juif alors là on aurait
vraiment entendu
avec la France insoumise n'aurait pas la
région pour le coup la raison ça c'est
sûr oui euh non il y a pas des
communautés plus importante je trouve
que d'abord c'est bien qui se soit
excusé et je trouve qu'il faut plus
qu'on entende ça parce que des cons 18
ans ils sont peut-être beaucoup plus
propre que ce qui se passe
comme un Raymond j'ai dit c'est quoi
c'est très grave parce que tu peux pas
après c'est eux surtout leur vie qui le
paye donc
c'est pas comme au sec parce que le souk
ça a marché et ça va pour oui mais
d'accord bordel
c'est là où ils habitent leurs quatre
c'est là où ils vivent derrière ils
trouvent pas de bande derrière alors
effectivement il y a des fois des des
débordements des mecs qui foutent le
bordel ils partent sans nettoyer on est
d'accord on est d'accord sur ça mais il
faut pas non plus stigmatiser parce que
si vous changez quand le Gitan et on le
dit là par un autre expression je peux
vous dire que ça fait plus de bras
merci euh 0 % partout et vous choqué non
à 68 %
mais parce que les gens
ils avaient des panneaux aujourd'hui
les gens sont forts
je vous ai imaginé avoir un enfant tous
les deux
merci Jean merci